activating brainwave transmissions NORs
in trouble we have to go in after her
see you dying there die out here she's
protecting her secret dad can't see
whenever we begin a handwriting analysis
[Music]
as I suspected the Journal of Nora
west-allen contains two different types
of handwriting so
there is a mastermind behind the scene
the only question is who
[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got brand-new
flash floods to break down it seems like
next week's episode is inception mixed
with Nightmare on Elm Street dream
warriors because Nora gets trapped in a
nightmare
and has to fight Freddy Krueger cicada
in Barry and iris going to try and pull
her out there's also some new evidence
to show why cicada in reverse flash are
not the main villains of flash season 5
it's another secret character that's
pushing the cicadas storyline along that
I'll explain during the video so there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and a whole
bunch of stuff we have to talk about
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a bladed
comment on the video so first big thing
this is the actual description that
explains the mechanics of how they wind
up in the dream world so it says when
Sherlock wants to use a memory machine
on Barry and Nora to help gain access to
Grace's memories that's cicadas niece
who's in the hospital in a coma right
now Nora secretly decides to use the
machine on her own which ends in
disaster after she gets trapped inside
Grace's mind Barry and iris go in after
their daughter and iris is brokenhearted
by what she finds meanwhile Ralph tricks
Cisco into going out for a night on the
town I'm guessing that the Cisco out on
the night for a town is supposed to be
more of a lighter story and all the
really WTF stuff will be happening
inside Nora in Grace's nightmares
because they'll be running from Freddy
Krueger cicada and Freddy Krueger
reverse-flash here so to speak the whole
reason for all this dream warriors
business is because team flash wants
access to Grace's memories to help them
find a way to heal her and to get cicada
to stop killing metas but I'm guessing
the logic that they're using here is
that the brainwave Machine signal goes
both ways so Nora thinks that by hooking
herself up with Barry it will give him
access to all of her secrets
so he'll wind up learning about all the
secrets that she has about working with
the reverse-flash in the future that she
doesn't want him to know about so she
flips her [ __ ] and preemptively hooks
herself up to Grace's mind with one of
those gauntlets and whatever she does
she is a master at messing things up in
a way that Barry could only hope to
achieve
so of course Nora doing something on her
own ends in complete disaster she warns
out trapped in Nightmare on Elm Street
flash Edition and you can see all these
shots of her running from cicada in this
hospital because this is supposed to be
Grace's
nightmare that she's trapped in but the
interesting thing that you learn here
though is that because grace is having a
nightmare of cicada that means grace
hates cicada which will be really
important detail for team flash when
they're looking for things that will
help them defeat cicada all they needed
it like if cicada loves grace and is
doing all this for her and learns that
grace hates all the things that he's
doing rejects him in real life he might
back off in the weird thing to tangent
is because that nurse that's been
helping him out seems really
trigger-happy she's the one that was
egging him on no you need to keep focus
you need to stay on all these meadows
here's a giant list of them for you to
go out and kill really big flash season
five theory this evil nurse is probably
keeping grace in a coma on purpose so
that cicada will keep on killing Meadows
because the whole idea is is that berry
is trying to wake her up so I wouldn't
be surprised they find some evidence for
that in her nightmare here but that
would make this evil nurse the real
villain of season five at least in the
present day cicadas storyline standard
dreamworld genre rules apply if Freddy
Krueger cicada kills Nora or anyone else
inside the dream world her body in real
life will also die so I'm guessing the
reason why iris is going to is is
because she wants to help and because
it's the dream world technically it
shouldn't matter whether or not you
actually have powers unless you're meta
powers are mental base like you're a
psychic or you're a telepath or whatever
your powers are they give you extra
power within the dream world but
technically Barry's Speed Force
abilities should not work the same way
like when you see him use his flash
powers inside the museum here to rush
that reverse flash without a face
usually stuff like that is regulated by
whoever is in control inside the dream
world so if you're the dreamer
technically you're the most powerful
person in there so if they're inside
Nora's memories then Nora's the person
controlling whether or not Barry's
powers actually work they're not really
clear on the mechanics of how graces
nightmare scape is tied to Nora's
memories of the flash Museum or if
they're bleeding together or if it's an
inception thing where it's just
different dream levels like the top
level is Nora's memory because they go
into her mind when she gets trapped in
the lower level which is probably
Grace's nightmare so the way they use
these different levels as metaphors like
the deepest dark
secrets are usually hidden in the lowest
level of whatever this memory scape is
so I'm guessing that by the end of the
episode they'll start to learn more
about her relationship with the
reverse-flash if it's not flat-out
reveal completely because as is that
final scene during flash episode 11
Sherlock learned about another person
that was helping her in the future so
I'm guessing that all the stuff that
they learned inside the memory of the
flash museum here just lets Barry know
that Nora is obsessed with the
reverse-flash but maybe he doesn't find
out exactly why like how come you're
thinking about the reverse-flash
so much how come we saw so much of him
inside your mind so they can leave the
actual reveal when Barry really finds
out what's going on a couple episodes
down the road because usually that
happens somewhere around the middle of
the back half of the season and that'll
probably be where they take the
reverse-flash storyline in the future in
the cicada storyline and present-day and
bring those together like right now
they're two separate storylines but by
the end of the season they should be one
in the same storyline when they say that
iris is supposed to be heartbroken by
what she finds in Nora's memories it's
probably just all the drama that they
had in the first couple of episodes
where Nora in future iris had like a
really crappy relationship because iris
is so afraid of her growing up and being
a speedster in the same thing happening
to her that happened to Barry you know
disappearing or dying during crisis on
Infinite Earths elongated man taking
Cisco out on the town in the other
storyline is probably just to get him to
chill out and realize that he can be a
superhero and have a normal life at the
same time that's the whole reason the
writers are justifying Cisco making this
cure even though Barry is able to have a
family and be the flash at the same time
I don't think that I can do that an
elongated man is probably just trying to
prove him wrong if you're wondering
where Cisco was this past week - I got a
lot of questions where's Joe and where
was Cisco this week they probably just
wanted to give the actor that plays
Cisco a week off or he has some other
prior engagement and he asked to take an
episode up like please just write me out
of a single episode so I can go do
something else
the explainer for Joe is a little more
complicated I think I talked about it in
a previous video the actor that plays
Joe West Jesse Martin injured his back
some time during the summer last year so
even though he was able to film a couple
episodes at the beginning of season 5 he
had to go on medical leave
so he just left the show so his back
could heal for a while the writers wrote
him out of the show but the showrunner
said that they would have an explainer
for where he's been this whole time and
it would be important for the cicadas
storyline it's not really clear how the
reverse-flash storyline them altering
the timeline is gonna completely help
them solve the cicada problem but the
whole idea this season is that Nora gets
smarter and smarter while she's messing
up trying to learn how to save her
father with the help of reverse-flash so
by the end of the season it'll all come
to a head she'll have some big epiphany
and reverse-flash will escape what seems
like his imminent death because that
seems what the ticking clock is all
about counting down to his execution
inside iron Heights prison but also at
the same time tea up or teas crisis on
Infinite Earths because that's like the
big thing that's happening next season
even though all the shows will have
their own storylines just like they
normally would for a new season crisis
is such a big event for the DC TV
universe that I'm expecting the finales
of all the shows to have some sort of at
least small teaser that lets you know
what's coming next season with that big
crossover biggest questions of the hour
though or what does that have to do with
what reverse-flash and Nora are doing to
change the timeline in what was Oliver
Queen's bargain with the monitor the
arrow showrunner revealed that they
would not tell us what that was until
next season on arrow early theory just
based on the tone of that conversation
Oliver Queen traded his life for berries
so he will be the one to die quota Coe
disappeared during crisis and not berry
my true self is filled with darkness
Barry and Cara are different
they inspire hope they inspire people
because they are the best of us and if
this test of yours is gonna kill our
best chance at stopping this crisis
[Music]
while his gods go
you're not a very smart one
the universe is a complex piece of
machinery and balance must be maintained
one change requires another
how would you propose I keep the balance
we probably won't hear more about that
until we get to comic-con and they drop
all the trailers for the new seasons but
post all your theories in the comments
below
congratulations jude adler you're the
giveaway winner from my last big flash
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so we can get your details
click here for all my flash season 5
episode 11 easter eggs
and click here for my new avengers
endgame teaser for all the new cameos
and the new avengers costumes thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]